and so what they think they're doing is
they're like well that's what everyone
else is doing so I need to build my
personal brand you're not building
anyone's [__] brand you're just
reinforcing an identity that everyone
already knows about and does not find
you interesting because you're same as
everybody else if you remember when you
were in middle school there was like the
preps and The Goth kids and then the
Bros or the athletes or whatever when
we're growing up we're trying to figure
out our identity and maybe some of you
weirdos actually switch tables once or
twice because you're figuring out who
you were and what happened is we learned
these identities that come with these
sets of beliefs you see this a little
bit in the political scene if you're a
republican all of a sudden you have to
wear a flannel and trucker has America
and to shoot guns and on the flip side
if you're liberal you have to just say
all homeless people can do whatever they
want whenever and we should let everyone
across the border no matter what we all
should raise taxes basically
Ridiculousness on both sides what
happened to the real middle people who
just like hey you can marry whatever you
want please don't tax me too much
there's this middle and that's why
people like Rogan have blown up because
people are like he's a republican he's a
liberal it's like he's just Joe Rogan
like Joe Rogan is interested in UFC he's
also interested in Aliens he's also
interested in stand-up comedy he also
has like like this kind of Fitness
carnivore or whatever thing going and
biohacking so he has these like very
different interests that he's super deep
on and no one would be like Joe so what
we're thinking is you need to increase
your biohacking by 15 so we can capture
this audience no if you want to stand
out in your marketing or even a personal
brand just actually saying what you
really believe the thing that you're
afraid of saying because it maybe is two
or three or four beliefs that don't go
with the uniform that you wear every day
actually makes you significantly more
unique most people wear their clothing
as a uniform to say I am this type of
person people will look at you and
they'll assume you're a goth or crap or
whatever here's where it gets cool you
start talk and then all of a sudden
there's something over here and then
there's another belief over here and
what happens is they start paying more
attention because you don't fit the mold
it's my favorite way to differentiate
any of the portfolio companies or even
my own brand this may sound crazy
actually just be myself because as soon
as someone feels like they have figured
you out they'll move on because they're
like I can predict all of this person's
Behavior they don't need to stay in tune
or stay updated because they know
everything about you already and I'm
sure you've met people like this he
wears this uniform he says these things
he believes he is this person he's
category 17. don't have to think about
it again everyone knows the starter kit
for Real Estate you know the haircut
they cut the side here right buzzed on
the side hard part hard gel over suit
don't forget the glass is very important
maybe the high level BMW mid-series wax
with rims maybe a picture of the a watch
he's like yeah just bought this beauty
those guys are all the same and so what
they think they're doing is they're like
well that's what everyone else is doing
so I need to build my personal brand
you're not building anyone's [__]
brand you're just reinforcing an
identity that everyone already knows
about and does not find you interesting
because you're the same as everybody
else I think that you would be better
served actually doing you and that comes
with all the weirdness that you are
because I've met some of you y'all are
weird as [__] and if you stop pretending
to be this identity that you rap into
the starter kit of whatever Instagram
influencer you're trying to copy and you
just worry you what happens is your
unique individual personalities are like
weirdness because everybody had
different parents everybody was born in
different cities everyone has unique
things like your dad might have been a
mechanic you might know a bunch of [__]
about cards and if you bring that up all
of a sudden people look at what they
expect from the real estate starter kit
and then all of a sudden you've got
these points over here and you become
interesting and people lean in they pay
attention because you don't match the
mold I'm going to shift this to business
there was this time where there was this
competitor who moved in my Marketplace
when I had a local gym guy was
outspeeding me and I was like man I'm
gonna have to do something about this so
what I did was I copied the guy's
landing page so I copied everything
changed the logo whatever it was like
probably 90 the same here's what's crazy
his page did worse than mine did why am
I copying this guy I actually just got
worse outcomes from this fast forward
our gym launch days somebody came to the
marketplace started marketing really
similar stuff I subscribed to the list
to see what the emails they were sending
and they were my emails literally 100
word for word didn't even like swap
anything out they were my email I'm like
man I'm thinking about copying this guy
but hopping on his newsletter he's just
using my [__] A lot of people say stay
in tune with your competitors you
consume everyone else's stuff I actually
don't feel that way I actually turned
off all my ads on my news feed when I
made my marketing or made my content I
just made it about whatever stuff I felt
like talking about and so people were
like man your stuff's always so
different and so original whatever and
it's really easy to be original you're
just not looking at everyone else's [__]
the act of consuming everyone else's
stuff what ends up happening is that
their thoughts become top of mind for
you and you become another Mickey Mouse
another Instagram influencer starter kit
they've got the what the car 100 hustle
zero percent grind if other people copy
you it's a good sign because it means
that what you're doing is working and
most people aren't original if you copy
them what it means is that you accept
the position of second place you accept
that they are inherently first you
literally say you are better than me at
this and if you claim to be the best at
whatever it is that you're trying to do
or at least that you're trying to be the
best you copying their identity their
look their feel their brand means that
you are accepting to lose you will never
win because you aren't going to beat
them at being them quick stories client
and our software company Alan who was a
real estate agency so we worked with
agency owners in that business and so
this guy was continually struggling like
you couldn't really ever break through
there and he was always selling new
people and they would always turn out
the back whatever it took me six months
of like just battering him over the head
with this publicly embarrassing him to
finally get him to change his behavior I
was like you're not that good it's not
some marketing hack it's not some sales
hackers like you're just not that good I
was like you you sell to Realtors he was
like yeah I was like have you ever been
a realtor he was like no then you have
no idea what they go through and what
your marketing looks like and what your
sales process looks like is the same as
every other [__] person trying to
sell Realtors promise you put your
terrible agency go take the 12 weeks
pass the test and actually be a realtor
sell some [__] houses using your
marketing skills that you claim to sell
in the first month of him doing this he
was like oh [__] he's like these leads
aren't as good as I thought they were I
was like no [__] that's why no one
wanted to keep paying you but you know
what he did over the next 12 months he
got better and better and better at it
and here's the crazy thing 12 months
later he actually still a realtor and
he's making more money because he
actually got good at it but here's the
thing if he had kept trying to look like
everybody else he would have been Mickey
mousing until he kept trying some new
thing or new some new hack but he just
didn't confront the work and you know
what happens now is that if he actually
did want to go back to the agency thing
and actually did want to help Realtors
he would have the context to do it and
it would make him unique because so many
other people are just like him
pretending to be to model their
Instagram page after the same things the
other influence that they're looking up
to does rather than being like I wanted
to figure out real estate most people
don't do that they just look what
everyone else is doing do the same thing
water it down and then literally blend
in like everyone else and they wonder
why they don't win you've heard me say
replicate before you iterate right that
comes to skills if you want to learn how
to sell right next to the guy who's
making calls you want to learn how to
knock on doors walk with the guy who's
the best guy on the team who knocks
doors right you duplicate the skill so
you know you can do it that's different
than replicating a story and replicating
an identity I've seen like hermosify and
hermosi style content and a Rosy style
edits it's not about the captions
it's about the content what they can
copy is the way it looks and feels and
sounds so what they can't copy is the
story behind it fix the story and the
brand will take care of itself if you
tell the story that's true and so if you
don't have the story to tell then do the
[__] that's worth doing that no one else
is willing to do and then you'll have
the story that will make you a
one-of-one